herzlich willkommen bei halle
deutschland ich freue mich dass sie
dabei sind in unserem corona kompakt
geht es um einen sinn produzenten der
gerade auf desinfektionsmittel
umschwenkt wir stellen ihnen einen
wochenmarkt vor der über das internet an
die haustür kommt und der theologe
professor wurde blatter von der uni
mainz ist später hier im studio für ihre
fragen und klar es geht natürlich auch
um die mit spannung erwarteten
beschlüsse der regierung heute besucher
haben hier keinen zutritt mehr auf der
krebsstation des universitätsklinikums
hamburg eppendorf
der grund das corona virus etwa 20
mitarbeiter und 20 patienten wurden
positiv getestet
die hier behandelten krebspatienten
gelten als besondere risikogruppe der
betrieb auf der station geht jedoch
weiter wie das virus hierhin gelangen
konnte wird momentan untersucht
nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind in deutschland stand
heute 16 uhr 30 132 1321 infektionen
durch tests bestätigt 72.600 menschen
gelten als genesen an gießens uniklinik
machen sich politiker in bild dabei hat
man durchaus nachholbedarf wenn es um
die eigenen schutzmaßnahmen aber nicht
nur masten und ihr korrekter gebrauch
sind ein thema sondern auch
kontaktverbot abstandsgebot
geschlossene schulen und geschäfte alles
maßnahmen welche die politiker nicht
unbegrenzt aufrechterhalten können in
bestimmte bereiche des einzelhandels
zeigen können dass das geht so wie die
supermärkte sonst ja auch zeigen jeden
tag dass es geht dann kann man das
sicherlich auch auf andere bereiche im
einzelhandel übertrag auch österreich
ist auf dem weg zurück zur normalität
baumärkte und kleinere geschäfte wie
dieser blumenladen sind wieder geöffnet
ich freue mich richtig dass wir wieder
da sein dürfen weil mir einfach der
kontakt zu unseren kunden auch schon ein
bisschen gefehlt hat
allerdings kommt man auch in österreich
nicht ohne regeln aus nur ein kunde auf
20 quadratmeter geschäftsfläche ist
erlaubt und das tragen einer maske ist
pflicht auch im öffentlichen nahverkehr
und unser heutiger experte hierbei
corona kompaktes professor dr bodo
cluster erst virologe an der johannes
gutenberg universität in mainz schön
dass sie wieder hier bei uns sind wie
beurteilen sie denn das was zumindest
bisher durchsickert aus berlin bund und
länder haben beraten beraten ja noch
kontaktverbot wahrscheinlich bis dritte
mai verlängert die schulen auch erst ab
dritten mal nicht ab nächster woche
wie sehen sie das als geologe ich glaube
das ist sehr sinnvoll wären wir sehen ja
alle die zahlen lieber im internet
beobachten können die jetzt abgenommen
haben es gibt einen trend wie auch das
lka berichtet hat aber es muss noch ein
bisschen geduld glaube ich gefordert
werden und das ist glaube ich der
zeitpunkt anfang mai habe ich gerade
richtig das heißt nächste woche schon zu
starten mit schulen und co das wäre ein
gewisses risiko und denke ich mal also
ich denke die zwei wochen sollte man
vielleicht noch warten das ist die
einschätzung machen die politiker auch
wir gucken gleich noch mal drauf ich
sage erst mal vielen dank professor
plachta und ich sage auch bis gleich
denn dann sehen wir uns hier noch mal
wieder für die fragen von ihnen liebe
zuschauer die wir heute auch wieder
haben
bis dahin geht es aber jetzt erst einmal
auf dem wochenmarkt aber nicht die
klassische variante also die mit
einkaufsnetz oder tüte über den markt
schlendern
da kommt der ganze wochenmarkt einfach
ins netz und zwar im internet eine idee
die schon vor corona entstanden ist doch
jetzt während der krise da ist sie
doppelt und dreifach erfolgreich
frisches obst gemüse fleisch und käse
direkt an die haustür
es sind lebensmittel von den ständen am
ulmer wochenmarkt gisela schwarz nutzt
den lieferservice gerne und unbeschwert
durch den wochen beim schlendern kann
und möchte so kann man halt dann auch in
unsere situation wie wir sie jetzt haben
auch weiterhin die lokalen landwirte
unterstützen
dabei war corona noch überhaupt kein
thema als michael meier zusammen mit
freunden die idee für den lieferservice
hatte die drei jungen männer hat gestört
dass sie oft an den markttagen keine
zeit hatten um hier einzukaufen
ihre lösung ein lieferservice der die
lebensmittel format direkt zu den kunden
nach hause bringt normalerweise klingeln
wieder stellen die die ware vor die tür
warten bis der kunde eröffnet dann
übernimmt er das ganze geliefert wird
rund um ulm immer an markttagen den
lieferzeitpunkt können die kunden selbst
bestimmen
die markthändler bringen ihre waren
morgens einfach mit an ihren stand das
team um michael meier stellt die
lebensmittel kisten dann wie von den
kunden bestellt zusammen und fährt sie
anschließend aus 89 die luft dann immer
an und bestellt so weil sie das internet
nicht so beherrscht wie sie selber meint
und aber sonst durch die bank im grunde
alle alle schichten die bei uns
bestellen
im regelfall hier im online shop der das
angebot vom wochenmarkt im netz bündelt
monate lang hat es gedauert von der
ersten idee bis zur umsetzung
auch weil viele markthändler erstmal
überzeugt werden mussten
wir haben ja viele landwirte die
teilweise mit
digitalen geschäft gar nichts zu tun
haben umso schöner ist dass wir jetzt
zum beispiel auch ein kartoffelbauer
haben der kriegt seine bestellungen per
fax und trotzdem daran der digitalen
welt teil
was sich vor allem in der aktuellen lage
auszeichnet als er das konzept läuft es
richtig gut an seite corona hat sich das
vor 38 bei ihrem einsatz für uns
natürlich von vorteil dass wir jetzt
während der noch schwieriger zeit
trotzdem online so viel verkaufen können
bis zu 100 bestellungen hat das
lieferstart mittlerweile pro markttag
ein boom durch die korona epidemie
und so haben sie inzwischen mit team
vergrößert auch studentin kira die
eigentlich in einem momentan
geschlossenen kulturzentrum job macht
nun hiermit nicht so eng beieinander
stehen beim arbeiten und wenn mir
auslief und audio hat er für ein
bisschen distanz haben und trotzdem hals
immer herzlich und freundlich bleiben
beim ausliefern der lebensmittel vom
wochenmarkt direkt an die haustür
für die idee die torsten frings aus
hamburg hatte bekam er zuletzt sogar
schon anfragen aus china oder von der
british royal mail also dem postdienst
aus großbritannien so heiß begehrt ist
ein klares produkt in diesen tagen
alkohol nämlich zur herstellung von
desinfektionsmitteln dabei stellt der
gastronom und unternehmer den eigentlich
immer nur in form von gin her oder rum
oder whiskey trinken kann man das nicht
was thorsten frisieren stylische glas
flaschen abfüllt aber nun kann sich
primär die hände damit desinfizieren
trinkt alkohol versetzt mit glyzerin
wasserstoffperoxid und destilliertem
wasser ein whu rezept
das ist vielleicht ein zehntel des
umsatzes den wir mit spirituosen machen
und zusätzlich fehlen uns natürlich die
direkten einnahmen in der gastronomie
oder ein sechsstelliger betrag aus
events die wir eigentlich fest gebucht
hatten also das schafft es bei weitem
nicht aufzuwiegen
aber versuchen das ein bisschen
abzumildern um aus der krise dann nicht
mit zu hohen schulden herauszukommen
denn sonst geht nicht mehr viel in der
bar still und leer ist es hier seit
tagen dort wo sonst in whisky und rom
aus der eigenen destille ausgeschenkt
werden cocktails in flaschen zum abholen
und selber mixen für zuhause thorstens
erste idee um sich über die zeit zu
retten
aber es ist das geschäft mit dem
desinfektionsmittel mit dem er sich
tatsächlich über wasser halten könnte
die idee entstand zusammen mit stammgast
ob er arbeitet in der apotheke seiner
frau desinfektionsmittel waren auf dem
markt nicht mehr zu bekommen
eine ausnahmeregelung erlaubt es
apotheken jetzt es selbst herzustellen
und da kam thorsten mit seiner destille
ins spiel
das war spontan also ich war hier um die
cockpits abzuholen hab dann wenn dann
mit thorsten ins gespräch gekommen dass
er sagte dass ethanol hätte wir waren
verzweifelt auf der suche nach
rohstoffen nach grundstoffen haben alles
abgegrast schon über unsere normalen
bezugs wege war nichts zu bekommen
in handarbeit produziert kostet so ein
fläschchen sechs euro 90 etwas mehr als
das industriell hergestellte mittel
verkaufen könnte man es zu einem viel
höheren preis aber thorsten will keine
notlagen ausnutzen
nach dem ersten schock hilft ihm das
projekt vor allem optimistischer in die
zukunft zu blicken und die anfängliche
lähmung zu überwinden
als bekannt wurde dass wir
desinfektionsmittel herstellen gab es
hebt arzt kliniken physiotherapeuten
aber auch große unternehmen chinesische
unternehmen die britische royal mail hat
angefragt ob die 1000 meter
desinfektionsmittel bekommen könnten der
britischen post musste er absagen
das übersteigt seine kapazitäten eher
verkauft vorrangig im viertel
stephan breuing holt gleich einen ganzen
kanister er hatte großen
desinfektionsmittel für seine
mitarbeiter auf den baustellen zu
bekommen
ganz schwierig
also an die letzten reserven sind so
aufgebracht und dadurch war ich ganz
froh dass sich über den kontakt wenn
mein sohn hier zu der stelle gekommen
bin und dieses das redaktions mittelbar
erwerben konnte was thorsten bei allen
eigenen problemen auch gut tut ist die
große dankbarkeit seiner vielen neuen
kunden rief eine physiotherapie an hier
aus der nachbarschaft und die dame hat
dort wird nicht gesagt dass wir hätten
ihnen leben gerettet und sie hätten den
betrieb einstellen müssen hätte sie
nicht in dem tag an dem tag oder einen
tag später desinfektionsmittel bekommen
denken muss ja auch an seine zwölf
mitarbeitern alle momentan in kurzarbeit
marie klebt etiketten startet am tresen
zu stehen staatliche soforthilfen sind
beantragt bislang ohne rückmeldung
postens vermieter ist abgetaucht den er
um kulanz bei der monatlichen miete bad
bis mai kann er so noch durchhalten dann
wird schwierig dennoch bleibt er
optimistisch plant schon für die zeit
nach corinna und hat einen crowdfunding
projekt gestartet crowdfunding bedeutet
dass die leute jetzt schon karten kaufen
können gästelistenplätze
und dann am abend des events nichts
bezahlen müssen sondern sie kaufen sich
jetzt eine karte und können dann sowie
der eröffnung kommen mit ihrem gäste
listenplatz nach der ersten eröffnung
vor nur anderthalb jahren wird bald neu
eröffnet daran glaubt thorsten ganz fest
getreu nach dem motto es ist nie zu ende
und es geht auch für die vielen fragen
die sie uns schicken geschickt habe um
rund um die korona krise die sind auch
noch nicht zu ende
und deshalb beantworten wer jetzt hier
wieder einige im studio professor bruno
platter vom institut für virologie der
universität mainz herzlich willkommen
nochmal wir starten direkt mit der frage
von hans peter egelsbacher der sagt dass
es bereits mutation des corona virus
gibt hat er gehört wie entstehen solche
mutationen und haben die auswirkungen
auf die entwicklung eines impfstoffs ja
diese wir müssen sich vermehren das
heißt sie müssen ihre genetische
information vermehren
dabei entstehen fehler und diese filter
sind meistens nicht gut dass wir uns
auch manchmal können sich dann diese
mutationen durchsetzen und verändern das
virus allerdings in der regel gibt es
eben bei solchen wir dann auch
strukturen an der oberfläche die dieses
virus braucht unbedingt braucht um zu
überleben und dagegen kann man eben
entsprechend antikörper quasi
produzieren lassen durch ein impfstoff
und damit ist eigentlich die mutation
dann vor
nicht so wichtig ok also fokus weiter
auf den einen impfstoff der irgendwann
hoffentlich kommt warum wird nicht
kortison eingesetzt fragt friedhelm
jäger im kampf gegen des krone wir uns
ja es hat sich gezeigt dass in der
frühen phase koalition nicht wirklich
hilfreich ist in späteren phasen
patienten kränker sind dann gibt es
einige heil versuche allerdings auch
ohne wirklich durchbrechenden erfolg das
heißt kortison hilft auch nicht so
wirklich offensichtlich
markus hat uns geschrieben und fragt
sich ob das corona wäre es auch
lüftungsanlagen verbreitet werden kann
und so eben dann menschen infizieren
kann ja das wird immer wieder gefragt
tatsächlich es ist so dass die
klimaanlage selber natürlich tröpfchen
eigentlich rausfiltern allerdings durch
den luftzug kann natürlich wenn jemand
hustet tatsächlich das material was er
aus rüstet weiter verbreitet werden und
auch zum beispiel in gaststätten dann
auch durch bayern durchaus mal den
nachbartisch erreichen und dadurch
natürlich dann infektionen unter
umständen weiter tragen aber ist dass
ein großer teil der dennoch über die
klimaanlagen am ende dann wieder in die
luft kommt meldet kommt nicht über die
klima und lagen sondern hat der luftzug
in der klimaanlage und dadurch
verbreitet sich das unter umständen im
raum in dem engen raum dann etwas besser
als wenn der luft eben steht aber da
gibt es auch wirklich keine wirklich
guten wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse
dazu morgen begrüßen reine theorie
tatsächlich weil wir alle ja immer noch
auf see als experte in der anfangsphase
stecken gibt es die möglichkeit fragt
eckert dierbach dass man das corona
virus mit medizinisch hergestellten
serum oder auch an die körperreaktionen
über infusionen bekämpfen kann fachfrage
ja das war im prinzip auch gehörigen
beitrag ja im prinzip dass man eben von
den personen die chinesen sind die
antikörper klasse gewinnt und dann eben
dem kranken infundiert da gibt es im
augenblick tatsächlich solche versuche
wir gesehen haben
ob das dann erfolg hat wird sich zeigen
auch das ist in der tat sich noch unklar
wie weit ist denn da die forschung bei
diesem bei dieser taktik auf der suche
nach dem impfstoff nach medikamenten ja
im prinzip wie gesagt es wird im
augenblick versucht die zellen werden
die pilger plasmen werden gewonnen und
werden dann eben entsprechend den
patienten verabreicht aber da muss man
natürlich auch noch warten wie die
studien sich wirklich entwickeln dann
auch da braucht man tatsächlich auch
hier noch wieder zeit um zu schauen was
sagen sie das ist die einschätzung der
zertifikate können durchaus wirksam
seien tatsächlich aber muss auch sehen
dass ist natürlich relativ dünn wenn man
so möchte ich relativ wenig antikörper
gesunden entnehmen kann da sind
vielleicht andere präparate die
künstlich quasi antikörper dann
herstellen dann vielleicht besser
wirksam aber auch das ist zukunftsmusik
muss man sagen leider in diesen tagen
joachim modell hat geschrieben oder
gefragt ob ein geheilt hat bei kontakt
mit einem infizierten viren aufnehmen
kann
und obwohl er selbst nicht erkranken
kann die viren dann an einen dritten
weiter geben kann dann somit übertragen
dafür gibt es überhaupt keine hinweise
dass jemand überhaupt noch mal wieder
infiziert werden könnte in dem sinne
dass er auch die viren vermehrt sondern
es sieht eher so aus als ob man dann
tatsächlich komplett geschützt ist auch
gegen virusvermehrung und weitergabe da
es ist nach wie vor ein spannendes feld
das ist vieles offen aber durch sie und
andere experten haben wir schon etwas
mehr einblick und viel viel mehr
einblick vielen dank für den besuch hier
im studio wo du frachter von der uni
mainz damit sind sie auch auf youtube zu
sehen
in unserem kroner kompakt das ist dann
nämlich jederzeit verfügbar und zwar auf
dem kanal der zdf heute dort